there's no time
[Music]
13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday main show day uh murder Hornet
says late are you asking if we're late
we're not late I mean it might be wrong
time well it might be because I don't
know change his clocks I'm trying to bet
he has well that's what I'm saying it
might be because or parts of the world
that don't do like because we did we
went back to like uh
back to regular time after daylight
savings time so I wish they would get
rid of that [ __ ] because it's like so
[ __ ] pointless but yeah we just uh
changed our clocks back last weekend or
something like that so nobody said
anything about it though so it didn't
really like occur to me that other
people might be like why are you guys on
like at a different time but it's not
it's like the same time for us it was
just because of the like clock changing
so you know but like I said I know that
some states and some countries don't do
that
and I kind of wish that we didn't but
you know what are you gonna do uh yeah
murder said it must be my phone I like
when it gets dark earlier I do as well
to be honest with you I mean I like just
like the regular time I mean I like this
time of year anyway
um you know summer can suck a dick I
just I'm not really a fan so
I like when it gets dark like you know
real dark in the evening and it's like
cool at night and
[ __ ] like that I don't I don't need this
summer a sunlight business
what you doing there Tom I'm trying to
get back to uh uh YouTube so I can see
the comment section Ben says the occult
world of daylight savings sitting back
here watching poop was watching the
we turned the fan off early he said
so we could hopefully like get her upset
upsetness like out of her because you
know how she gets like when we turn the
fan on yeah she gets like really
unsettled she doesn't understand and she
just like starts yelling at us like
we're it's like just please do something
about it I don't understand like and
she'll yell like through the whole
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay oh you're back here
I'm back now okay well I'm back I just
gotta get this [ __ ] [ __ ] right
there you go
okay look at you back there your little
Mr cleanass are you trying to stay on
Bob yeah of course I'm Bob you tried to
say I'm bald no of course not of course
not
I kind of feel like I don't know you see
he already said like before we started
the live stream he already said this is
gonna be a wild show and I was like I
feel it's gonna be a wow show really
yeah yeah I mean it's such a grim topic
though it's just gonna get crazy but
that probably doesn't matter it's just
gonna get crazy let's see who's gonna
come okay well now I better because now
you can't disappoint it
[Laughter]
because he's gonna say that earlier that
it turns out just being really boring it
might be boring
I don't think so our show's ever boring
is it I don't think so
[Laughter]
okay they're still coming in yeah okay
that's good what's up poop all right so
today's topic are family suicides Mass
family Mass family suicide these two
cases
um they're not like hugely hugely long
but they somebody and I can't remember I
think it was two different people but
two different people like recommended
each of these cases to me separately
and I kept putting them in the polls but
they never won but then like last time
last week it finally did win and then
when I started like looking into them
um I was kind of like well these two
cases are really similar uh so I'm just
gonna like put I'm like not similar
similar but they're I don't know like
the motives are kind of similar so I
decided that I was going to put them
together and like I said because the one
case like the atoms the atom house
there's not like a huge amount of
information about this because both of
these happened the atom house case that
happened in Bangladesh and the second
one happened
um the Ferrari deaths that happened in
India so a lot of the sources
um are not in English so the atom house
I found like a couple things about it
the berrari deaths actually
um has a Netflix uh mini series about it
which I actually watched most of like
earlier today like I kind of like
scrolled through it like to get notes
and stuff but I found a couple more
extensive write-ups on that so there's a
lot more information out there about
that one so if you have Netflix there
there's a documentary on there called
House of Secrets
that's about the berrari deaths and I
think I watched like the first episode
and then most of the second one I just I
don't know if it's like three episodes
or four episodes I didn't look but I
didn't have time to like finish watching
it but there was kind of like a big
write-up about it so you know so I got a
lot of information from that
um Ben says the show's never been boring
for as long as I've been able to stay
awake yeah
yeah it's funny
I mean you know I try not to move I mean
we try to keep it interesting but you
know how would I you've done a lot of
shows yeah probably a thousand of them
by now huh easily well we're on episode
This is actually episode of the main
show this is episode 325. yeah but all
the other ones but that doesn't count
like all the movie reviews and yeah we
do three times of this and all the other
ones we've done so probably yeah we've
got to be approaching a thousand videos
at this point like including all the
live streams and right matinee shows and
then including my movie reviews and book
reviews and [ __ ] like that right that's
what I was thinking yeah I mean it's got
to be approaching I would imagine
grandpa says Robert Eggers is making
Nosferatu with Bill Skarsgard and Lily
Depp ooh ooh that's gonna be good I bet
that's gonna be good we'll see I mean
Robert Eggers he's the [ __ ] he made the
lighthouse he made uh the witch
so maybe you can do it in black and
white
that yeah I I imagine that's something
he would do because like I said he's one
of those real hardcore [ __ ]
where he's like I want this to look
exactly well look what he did with the
lighthouse what if it's silent
see now that would be neat I kind of
feel like maybe they should do that yeah
I mean
Lighthouse is a [ __ ] trip man I still
can't believe I saw that [ __ ] movie I
loved that baby that was weird as [ __ ]
that was weird as [ __ ] you might like
the witch too I'm not real sure like you
might either really like it or really
hate it I'm not really sure I like the
lighthouse yeah but you might like the
witch too that was his other movie that
came out in 2016.
um
ah okay so everyone's saying like good
morning good evening depending on where
they are in the world murder Hornet
returns had never heard of this I had
actually never heard of it either and
like I said
um I we probably wouldn't have done a
show on it unless it hadn't been like
recommended because I there's like I
said there's not really a lot of English
language uh [ __ ] out there about these
two cases particularly the Adam house
case I couldn't find hardly anything
about it
um but like I said the Ferrari deaths is
a little bit better known because at
least there's a Netflix documentary
about it that I watched that was that
was like partially in English it was
like dubbed in English
so well not dubbed but it was kind of
like translated in English so I watched
a lot of that earlier today and it was
actually like really good uh Rebecca
said I've tried watching the witch but
it's so slow I'll finish it eventually
yeah well I wouldn't like it then that's
what I'm saying but I don't know you
might though I liked it
granther said the lighthouse is an Odd
Couple Comedy with a mermaid
the mermaid though yeah from what I
remember I don't think he ever saw the
mermaid I kind of want to see it again
yeah yeah Ben said silent and black and
white I hope I think that's kind of the
the way to do it maybe that's why Robert
Eggers wanted to do it because he's like
I'm making a modern version of Nosferatu
except make it silent black and white
like back in the old days you know what
I mean like what's his name did with
like begotten back in the 90s where he
made it look like a silent movie from
like the 20s and it was all [ __ ] up
like and
[ __ ] like that you probably didn't see
that movie did you that's like
that that was a weird-ass movie it
looked like a [ __ ] nightmare
and Willem Dafoe whacking off to a big
light bulb yep that was all in there too
that was all in there too I mean you
know
that's I forgot about that
there's a meaning to that movie but I
couldn't quite grab
there was some kind of meaning to it
there was yeah uh I'd have to go back
you've probably read an analysis already
what it was yeah although it's been a
while it was some kind of a metaphor for
something else yeah or an allegory it's
all allegory I think that yeah it was uh
John Smith said my favorite version of
Nosferatu is shadow of the vampire yeah
which we brought up before
um that's actually like a not it's like
about the making of nosferante you've
never seen it she says I need to see it
it's good it's really good like it's
wilmed if I was in it yeah but it's like
I said it's about the making of the
movie like back in the 20s but it posits
that Max Shrek the guy that played
Nosferatu was an actual vampire yeah
makes sense but it's like not I was
gonna say it's not a comedy like it kind
of is like it has like kind of like
black comedy elements but it's actually
kind of played like a drama but then it
has like funny stuff in it too like in
horror stuff in it too I don't know it's
like a really weird movie and I really
dig it I think I saw it in the theater
matter of fact okay so it's like early
2000s I think it was
um let's see uh Rebecca said oh is there
a mermaid in that movie I'll finish the
lighthouse eventually also
yeah and murder Hornet said don't like
slow burner movies I I
men's it depends if there's I don't mind
them usually but
it depends on like what the payoff is or
what it what exactly it is that you're
trying to do like sometimes I think that
you know people do it just because I'm
like oh I'm being already or whatever
but it's like if you actually have a
reason for it being like that then it
doesn't bother me looks like the glasses
have been popular do you guys like the
uh Jenny's new reading glasses I've been
getting some my my big ass eyes yeah
I've been getting so people are sending
you messages about it yeah yeah Patrick
Patrick and his girlfriend sent the
message says that do you look cute in
those glasses yeah that's like
supervised yeah well he knew that I that
I came up with that yeah that you came
up with that yeah I'm the one who got
the glasses freaking out he said the
little kids I came up with it yeah I'm
your Style Council
just like that band there's a thing
called style yeah okay yeah let's see
[ __ ] I don't know what kind of band was
it like a new wave was it New Wave all
right I think yeah I kind of remember
them they were British right I'd buy
used I had to buy used to do reading
glasses once a month
you gotta you gotta join me a little
like the reading glasses Club because
I'm sure there is one there's a month
there's a monthly subscription service
for literally everything yeah it is
everything just different reading
glasses
there's a perfume one there's the steak
one there's a [ __ ] Pizza one there's
a beer one there's a wine one there's
like every single [ __ ] thing there's
a vitamin one everything okay
um
yeah John Smith said an underrated art
horror movie is possum by the guy that
created uh Garth Murray's dark place I
loved possum I actually did a review of
it on
uh flickers of fear a few months ago I
kind of feel like it was
um but yeah possum is great it's like
it's super super creepy I was really
really into it
um Danny Rowling is asking Rebecca if
people in Australia actually believe in
the yowie
didn't we talk about the yowie on yowie
was a white dude
that's it no it's like a monster like a
like a well it's not like a Bigfoot is
it like a Sasquatch no I'm saying in
Hawaii a Howley is a white man oh so
it's like a completely different country
in a completely different word Tom it's
yeah yeah what was it
a Yowie a Yowie yeah yeah in Australia
it's like it's like a Sasquatch
it's like [ __ ]
honky calm yeah
I think when we did a show about
Cryptids I think we talked about a Yowie
on the vanilla gorilla yeah that's you
yeah
because I remember yowie was like
because that was like one of the cool
coolest names although not as cool as
like what was that other um what was
that other monster that had like a
really cool name that I couldn't stop
saying it started with a p but I can't
remember what it was uh
[ __ ] man
[ __ ] it'll probably come to me like in
10 or 15 minutes
Southern Yeti we have swamp uh what is
it called let's go again it's gun Cape
swampy what the [ __ ]
Florida skunking no it wasn't bun yet if
we didn't talk about the bunyip on there
but
what the [ __ ] Puck wedgie the puck
wedgie okay I don't even remember like
what the puck wedgie was supposed to be
I think he was supposed to be like a
little Gremlin or like a little gnome or
something but I was like man that's an
awesome name for a monster a puck Woody
I have no idea
who gave up with that but it's like
pretty cool
ah
uh Rebecca said by the way I do love the
frames Jenny I need glasses also bigger
frames doesn't hide our makeup yeah
that's true
uh John Smith said Australia is legit
filled with scary enough monsters no
need to have been new ones
yeah I want to see bullet ants myself in
action I spent a whole day just [ __ ]
with the bullet ants see what they do
I I don't know yeah I've heard of them
yeah bullet ants they're more like wasps
yeah they're an ant they're Crossing an
ant and a wasp
ants that don't cooperate they even
fight them they fight each other and
they're from the same nest yeah yeah
yeah
they work together sometimes they're
really like aggro yeah yeah they work
together sometimes and then they [ __ ]
kill [ __ ] they're poisonous if I
remember correctly they got Stingers on
it of course they are yeah like I said
everything in Australia is like
a pup wedgie yeah yeah that's a totally
different thing I'm pretty sure it's
Puck wudgy like p u k
w d g i e maybe there's a c in there but
I don't think there is and I can't
remember what it was I thought it was
like a little I don't know like a little
gnome or something like a little gnome
or [ __ ] Gremlin or some [ __ ] like
that I don't know something like that
something like that so uh yeah so what
else are we gonna talk about before we
get into the actual cases do we have
anything else that we have to like talk
about because it does seem kind of like
wow we're only we only like [ __ ]
around for like 15 20 minutes yeah we
actually got into the actual topic it's
like really really weird
[Laughter]
you know which is really weird and like
I said these are not like
the Adam house in particular is not like
super complicated so probably only take
me like five or ten minutes to talk
about that but like the other thing is a
little bit more complicated and it's
kind of it has like a little bit of a
weird cult angle to it like a little bit
so maybe we can like talk a little bit
about that something just came to mind
did they uh cancel the club night at
what's called they're moving it to
um the Friday after Thanksgiving okay
because they're worried about
um the tropical storm okay so yeah I got
a message this weekend
if you want I mean
um unless you didn't want to go well you
know I don't want to be broke but yeah
we we can if you've got money would like
to if you want to go I'll just go solo
you're like oh you ain't going nowhere
by yourself
don't ride back on that damn motorcycle
yeah I don't think that would be a good
idea yeah yeah that'd be fun I don't
know I would have done that I did that
[ __ ] all the time when I was [ __ ]
young man you start doing whatever man
needs to start doing what he did
the dumb [ __ ] you used to do when you
were young
I mean the reason
you should just be happy that you made
it to this age all the stupid [ __ ] that
you did back then no are you are you
going through a midlife crisis Tom first
midlife I think a long time ago are you
gonna are you gonna like buy a Ferrari
no no just get a 20 year old girlfriend
like that uh no uh you had to think
about it first yeah
those [ __ ] girls in their 20s are
[ __ ] stupid
uh but no the the
Ferraris are a waste of money if you ask
well yeah every time you see a Ferrari
you look who's behind who's driving it
and you're like you Snicker a lot of
times you're like yeah okay dude if I
can uh no you just need a [ __ ] cool
Mustang really or a Corvette that's all
I like the older older cars really you
know but yeah yeah
I'd love to have a [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] old boss Mustang and [ __ ]
[ __ ] Resto modded out with the right
suspension on it
[ __ ] updated engine package and but
they're old cars you know but there's
something about the way they looked
it's like a woman you know what I mean
sometimes an older woman [ __ ] if
she's [ __ ] Resto mod and she looks
real good
yeah you know restoration modification
oh yeah I know what that means I just
thought that that was funny that yeah
I'm a Resto mod
I'm a [ __ ] Resto mod what are you
talking about
but uh okay
John Smith said can't do the dumb [ __ ]
you used to do when young how many young
men's last words or watch this yeah yep
hold my beer yeah hold my beer um well
you get to the point to where
you don't care as much about the [ __ ]
that you used to do you're smarter now
but you know just how it is
murder Hornet said I've always wanted
the exact canary yellow Porsche in that
movie Commando yeah I kind of remember
that yeah I remember that car I haven't
seen that movie in a while but yeah I
kind of remember that remember Ray dong
Chong's [ __ ] Fiat Spider I had one of
those oh yeah yeah one of those I
remember that yeah I remember you
talking about it's a piece of [ __ ] man
[ __ ] hard to keep that thing running
it's hard to find parts
but uh you could probably do it now but
I would have replaced all that now
I'd have pulled that engine actually
problem wasn't the engine it was [ __ ]
like wiring and hoses and
funky breaks and really bad quarter
panels that rusted out you're constantly
[ __ ] trying to above the front rear
tires would rust water would get in
there and it wouldn't drain it would
rust out through there they had improper
[ __ ] galvanization of the [ __ ]
panels I would have pulled off now it is
I'd have pulled that all off and put
some kind of fiberglass kit in there
reduced a bunch of weight off of it and
put a [ __ ]
like a Ford V8 engine out of a [ __ ]
Crown Victoria and it put a
put a Mustang GT intake on it good
[ __ ] divorce dual [ __ ] Thrush
Mufflers Maybe
that thing would have [ __ ] flew
if you got the weight off of it put a
right engine in it it was cute it was a
good looking car man girls loved it a
little convertible
it's bigger than a Miata it's kind of
like a [ __ ] eight bit a little bit
bigger than an AC Cobra it is cool car
it's just they weren't really made out
of anything Fiat wasn't a good company
Florida dude says Fiat fix it again Tony
I'd always heard Ford was fixer repair
daily
[Laughter]
in certain areas I don't know that's
like oh my dad they were nowhere near as
bad
the word the worst were British cars but
it was mostly just the electrics
but that's old [ __ ] now yeah the Italian
cars were actually Italian cars from the
70s and the 80s were actually better
than
British cars from the 70s and the 80s
it didn't look as cool though the
British knew how to make a car look
but they just used Lucas electrics and
bad switches and they
you had to work on them a lot
they were just [ __ ] made up out of
what they had you know
gum and sticks yeah well it was like
cottage industries you know you had a
company's four or five different
companies making alternators and they
just kind of used that same alternator
on any old car and
just made up out of stuff that they were
already making and it may not have
worked out the combination of parts that
they used and quality control wasn't
that good and the worst part really for
the British cars in that era if I cannot
remember as a kid you know they'd fall
under our hands there is that every
[ __ ] wire underneath the hood would
snap and there just wasn't enough copper
in the wire it was more tin than copper
and the heat would get to it and
everything would just [ __ ] snap break
after time
everything had to be replaced
murder Hornets so they uh they want a
Karmann Ghia those are cool Cameron gear
was this I remember Volkswagen bug with
a different [ __ ] body on it yeah
pretty much yeah there's still a cute
car
you could do a lot with it
you put the right engine in it it was
good
they were fast for what it was you know
pretty neat Rebecca also said there was
a hundred thousand dollar plus Mustang
up for a raffle win here a few weeks ago
I don't understand why Ford was 100K I
did take pics though nice looking car
[ __ ] Mustang has a [ __ ]
Fierce following they have some [ __ ]
high-end Mustangs that are just a [ __ ]
I don't know anything that was a cobra
or above is pretty good like I mean look
cool and everything like that but I'm
kind of more of like a practical I just
want a car that goes from place to place
well I was a thing about the Mustang
what it looks like the Mustang was
practical it was a two-door family car
really and a back seat that you could
put people in it you could groceries you
could shop for groceries in it it got a
decent gas economy real good Automotive
reliability even the old ones were
pretty reliable they were good
and they and it kind of looked like it's
something that would be uh I wouldn't
call it a muscle car I wouldn't call it
a sports car just a sporty family car
but then you start putting
300 horsepower plus engines 400
horsepower plus engines in those things
and they were hot
it sounded good
John Smith said my first car was a
British classic and Alvis if you know
you never heard that one never heard of
that one I've heard of it but I can't
conjure up an image
Glenn little said my polish friend owned
a Soviet cardboard car
that's like pretty funny were they
actually made of cardboard no
no actually a lot of the Soviet stuff
was
primitive but made pretty well a lot of
the subject not made of gum and sticks
what's that not made of gum instead no
made out of beer and Legos now most most
of them from from what I've heard I've
never seen one they were just kind of
like Volkswagen bugs really they they
were reliable
they're No Frills though you know and
they'd make the same thing forever it
was that kind of [ __ ]
jeffyard said my dream car is a dark
blue 1964 VW Beetle just like the one my
grandma used to own
I still like the old like uh 60s and 70s
VW Beetles I thought they were cool like
my cousin had one he had one that was
like bright yellow but then like his
family had one that was I think they had
a blue one or they had a bright red one
and that red one was like really really
pretty
so I kind of liked when they remade when
they redid
the VW bugs when did they do that in the
2000s yeah early they weren't they
weren't like 90s they weren't quite as
cool looking as the old ones but they
were still pretty cute they were so
pretty cute
uh Dana Rowling's talking about honor
killings because this is not because
that's like not I guess that's kind of
similar to this but this is not um these
two cases are more like Mass like a
whole family that like committed suicide
like the same time around and we'll
actually get to the case really you
actually stop bullshitting around no
[ __ ] during the case too but it was
good that's true that's true yeah
because like yeah just let me like do a
paragraph and then if you have anything
that you want to throw in that you could
throw in so you're saying don't
interrupt no I'm just saying that you
did something that's not what I said
all right he takes everything like the
worst possible he takes everything the
most possible way like I'm like picking
on you or something no I'm just saying
because it's easier for me like to just
kind of like you know read a paragraph
and then like you know see if you have
anything to like say about that go ahead
so this first case that we're gonna be
talking about like I said this I don't
have a huge amount about this one
there's not a lot in English about it
it's just basically known as the atom
house or maybe it's Adam I'm not really
sure but it looks like Adam so that's
what I'm gonna say so this actually
happened in 2007
in Bangladesh now I don't I don't know
it doesn't necessarily want to bury the
lead so this is nine members of One
family
who all committed suicide by
jumping in front of a train what
which nine members jumped in front of a
train of the same [ __ ] family
yeah and people witnessed this
yeah wow okay can you imagine Bangladesh
Bangladesh okay well that yeah it's
similar to India yeah the second one
happened in India but this one happened
in uh Bangladesh I know they do things
you know like they had a long history of
wives killing themselves when the
husband dies
throwing herself throwing herself on the
funeral pyre yeah I've heard about that
well and I was like
I've also heard that sometimes they're
just thrown on there but I don't
yeah like what if like culturally are
you expected to and if you're like yeah
I'd rather not they're like oh you're
out you're going you know so that might
have happened too which is horrible yeah
yeah but well these people these people
like they seem to like kind of know what
they were doing
um it's weird because I wrote about like
a bunch of cases where
um people committed suicide there was
kind of a rash in like between their
early 20th century like in England of
people killing themselves by jumping in
front of a trains and I was like why the
[ __ ] would you do that
like not just
without any guns well no but I'm just
saying that from a from a standpoint of
I mean if you're gonna kill yourself I I
would at least try to do it like in the
least messy way possible just in
deference to like the person that
actually has to find your carcass yeah
um I don't really want to have to like
think about some poor [ __ ]
having to scrape my ass off the [ __ ]
railroad track that's horrible why would
you subject somebody to that that just
seems like the people that it seems a
little bit [ __ ] people that have
committed suicide have a lot of internal
conflicts I know but um worst I've heard
of was uh when I was living in Boston up
there on Summer Hill
uh or Winter Hill excuse me um across
the hallway from me was a woman and her
boyfriend lived in there and she was a
mental health
uh consultant or something she was she
took care of outpatients mental
outpatients
and there was a girl that was one of her
outpatients
who uh poured gasoline over herself and
the in the [ __ ] bed and set herself
on fire and stayed in that [ __ ]
Burning Bed
for you know
seconds a long time well I'm sure it's
it takes a really long time like when
you're on fire yeah she actually died
from breathing in those Flames from all
that screaming and then it burned down
the apartment that she was in
or or part of the apartment
so they're not thinking rationally when
they did it yeah I know that but I'm
just saying that
I don't know is it particularly ones
where they planned them and stuff like
that that just seems like kind of shitty
a shitty thing to like subject other
people to because somebody has to like
clean you up and it and I knew the
details I was like well why did she do
that she told me
and you know I'm not naming any names or
anything you know because I didn't know
the girl's name
she had been
um
sexually kind of take uh abused by her
dad from an early age
and she just couldn't get it out of her
head and there's a lot of internal
conflicts because she like loved him or
loved her dad you know he was nice to
her but
she felt like she had to be punished
type of deal so she in a way she's
punishing herself
but she wasn't thinking right she
[ __ ] put everybody else in jeopardy
too you know what I mean burning down
and so there was kind of like a bunch of
symbolism there she's burning herself
inside her own bed
yeah you know which she didn't say that
I said that I was like oh in her own bed
she set herself on fire yeah it was like
an allegory there you know because of
symbolism
but well I remember when it happened she
told me when she told me about what she
told me because it had happened that day
yeah
the trip
so it's a lot of these suicides [ __ ]
look weird people jumping in front of
trains jumping out buildings
breathing in gas out of the damn [ __ ]
stove you know just they do stuff like
that but sometimes it's symbolic
yeah sometimes they choose a particular
way like for that kind of reason right
like you said I kind of feel like maybe
and that's really sad because I kind of
feel like a lot of
um a lot of people that went through
sexual abuse yeah
um blame themselves which they
absolutely should not but you know
saying should not and don't yeah I mean
that's two different things that's what
she told me she said it was she had a
bunch of internal guilt
about it yeah so that's what I mean even
though because you I mean a lot of them
do blame themselves even though like I
said there's you shouldn't but that's
you know that's easy for people to say
like they do anyway
John Smith said living in London for a
time you would sometimes hear
announcements such as train canceled due
to incident Blackfriars usually meant
someone had jumped in front of a tube
yeah I heard that that still happens
um
yeah Danny rolling said a digital bath
is probably the best way to go AKA
electrical Appliance being dropped in
full tub in my opinion no that might not
actually kill you though and I kind of
feel like that would probably be
horrible
no America's tried
test tried and proven the firearm is the
way to go
yeah
and if you don't want to go that way
drug overdose or alcohol overdose I kind
of feel like that would probably be the
better one get you down oh man I want to
get in trouble yeah yeah don't like tell
people to do it yeah yeah there's ways a
fifth alcohol can kill you
if it goes into the right hole
yeah if you understand what I'm talking
about
yeah get your damn douchebag
pour that [ __ ] in there [ __ ] watch
what happens to you and you rig that
[ __ ] up so [ __ ] once you lose
Consciousness there's no way to [ __ ]
for anything
to [ __ ] lose contact and that [ __ ]
[ __ ] Pours Down it's in there [ __ ]
you're dead quick
and at least you're gonna be in a
[ __ ] embarrassing compromising
position where they find your dead body
that's what I'm saying
[ __ ] take you out fast even though
you'll be dead yeah I'm very cognizant
of the fact that it's like well somebody
is gonna have to find that yeah so you
don't really want I mean even though
I'll be dead and I won't know but it's
like you don't really want people
talking about that you don't want to be
like a funny story right you know at the
morgue or something yeah like ideally I
would think you could probably run a
hose down your throat and poor [ __ ]
fifth alcohol in it that vodka or
something that that'd kill you too but
unless you were a hardcore alcoholic
that had a resistance but I think they'd
even kill them because the rate of
induction is very high
you know but still uh I think it would
take a while you'd know that it was
happening but they say the other end is
[ __ ] a lot faster
because there's that's the ends part of
the [ __ ] digestive tract it goes
directly into the [ __ ] bloodstream or
you could just give yourself an IV of
[ __ ] pure alcohol but a lot of people
don't know how to handle needles or give
an IV to themselves
but a [ __ ] IV thing on the end of a
damn [ __ ] inverted [ __ ]
vodka bottle you'll [ __ ] be
unconscious in seconds
that [ __ ] going into directly into your
bloodstream
that'd do it
verica Z says Hey guys long time no see
who is this varic is he okay hope you're
doing well I have a story of my fiancee
jumped in front of a subway train going
full speed so I know what it's like it's
so horrific not in a right frame of mind
yeah I mean that's you know I'm really
sorry about that that's like that is
[ __ ] horrible you know she jumped or
she was she where she pushed
I imagine he you must know I mean he
must know he I said yeah he jumped
yeah listen
um slasher Fred if you guys ever watch
that Twilight Zone episode long distance
call oh I remember that one Billy's late
grandmother tries to get him to commit
suicide by getting him to jump in front
of an up oncoming car yeah that's right
John Gore said life is long you can just
smoke and drink yourself to death and
just enjoy right
so my uncle did drank himself to death
took about a month
yeah it totally told everybody was doing
they did two trips to the hospital
before it finally killed him
Ben says uh might have to delete this
episode from your catalog don't want to
get banned for discuss discussing
self-deletion yeah
uh verica said oh he jumped all right
there's foot video footage of it and
there was a girl on the platform I'm
freaking out right now it was horrific
and I don't know where yeah that's yeah
it's [ __ ] horrible [ __ ] horrible
but yeah so yeah I'm sure this is not
only going to get demonetized it might
actually be good man I don't know like I
think one time we did a show where we
kind of that was about like no actually
like on my True Crime Channel I did um a
show about a girl who was pushed off a
train and at first they thought she had
committed suicide but then they found
out later that she had been pushed off a
train yeah and they actually were not
they weren't gonna pull it but they were
just gonna basically uh they had all
kind of restrictions on it and because
they thought that I was talking about
like self-harm or something like that
but actually like I uh you know
what what's the what's the word I I
fought it yeah yeah and then they were
like oh you're right it's fine and they
like um left it because I was like the
one the girl didn't even commit suicide
she somebody pushed her
um but there was that and then like they
started sending me messages like
thinking I was gonna commit suicide like
they were like yeah I was all right yeah
that's what I mean it's so usually if
you kind of like just send him a message
and be like bro like watch it again like
they'll get a human to watch it it'll be
like oh okay it's fine but you know what
I mean so it's that kind of thing yeah
it's always like the AI that Flags it
just because of the word but like I said
so yeah I don't know um
I don't think I [ __ ] spelled anything
out well enough for AI to understand
what it was I was talking well that's
the thing though it's like I'm sure that
it's probably I mean what we just said
was like way worse than what I said on
that other video so uh so probably yeah
I don't know how that well that's gonna
go so I'm gonna have to like um probably
download we'll just keep an eye out I'll
just have to download this um you know
what I mean before like as soon as it's
available for me to download so that's
what I mean that's what I usually do
anyway because I back up every single
one of these live streams I have them
all
so in case anything ever gets taken down
or something I can put it back up or put
it up somewhere else so as soon as
they're over
well usually like as soon as they're
over like you have to wait 24 hours
maybe like 24 hours and then you can um
or no 12 hours rather and then you can
uh download it so I usually keep them
and then I upload them to my Dropbox
but so yeah so all nine of these this
family members uh jumped in front of a
train
now they think that it was probably
because the reason it's called the atom
house or they're called the atom family
I don't know what their real last name
was or anything like that like I said
there's not a huge amount about this
case
but they actually believed in this
religion which they called the Adam or
Adam religion which I guess they had
invented and it was like in um like
founded by their dad Abdul Adam who had
actually died seven years prior to like
so in 2000
um so I think like all of the family
members died except I think there was
one that didn't participate like a
daughter of theirs that either lived
somewhere else or she was like yeah no I
don't want any part of that now the
thing about this was maybe the reason
that they did it they think
was because of the of these weird
religious beliefs that they had nobody
is entirely sure like they asked all
their neighbors and all that other kind
of stuff they said well we weren't
really sure like what their exact
religious beliefs were like they
supposedly had this
you know Adam religion or whatever it
was that they had kind of like that the
dad had kind of invented
um they had started out as Muslims but
then like after the dad died in 2000
they actually converted to Christianity
or so they said
um but they didn't really do any
Christian stuff like they didn't go to
like you know Christian Services or
anything like that
and then like later on after they killed
themselves they found like all these
Diaries
and in the diary they were basically
like trying out like different religious
systems I guess they said at one point
they were even like considering uh
worshiping Kali which you know I'm not
sure how that become thuggies then
pretty much like yeah so I guess they
were just trying to like kind of figure
out like a way that would make them feel
better or something like that
okay like after the dad died if you
become a thuggy you're basically trying
to become a criminal family a mafia
that's what the thuggies were kind of
like well I know that but I'm just
saying that it seemed more like they
were just playing religion roulette like
they were just kind of like looking for
something that would give them some kind
of
um
like I said would make them feel better
about their father's death because it
seems like they couldn't really handle
it was you know what I'm saying their
economic problems maybe they couldn't
well like I said I don't know a huge
amount about it um everybody just kind
of said well they the main element of
the main thing about
joining a Sugi or a thug cult was that
you you could become a mafia or a
professional thieves so
they must have been that they needed
money
maybe he died but I don't know but the
thing about it is that I think you're
getting like two wrapped up on that one
little thing that was just like
something that they mentioned like in
the diary and like I said they were
trying out lots of different things okay
like I said they actually converted to
Christianity but then they were like oh
maybe we should try this Kali worship
thing or you know what I mean it's
almost kind of like they were just going
to like a religion buffet and seeing
it's like hey let's try this one out
because this one didn't work or you know
what I mean
and they also said they found out that
uh in the week prior to
um you know them actually jumping in
front of the train
was that they had tried to commit
suicide like twice already uh they had
actually like got all their coffins all
prepared and had dug Graves like in
their Garden for themselves so yeah
now so this is this is kind of the same
thing that happens in the Ferrari case
too which we're going to talk about
later on
but they found Diaries in their house
where they had kind of like um you know
written down all this stuff
and apparently what they were looking
for and the reason that they called it
like the the religion the Adam religion
was that they wanted to live like a
completely Pure Life like the life that
was lived by Adam and Eve like before
all the bad [ __ ] in the Bible happened
like in order to me like everything is
like pure and sinless and whatever so I
think they also wanted to kind of like
free themselves from adhering to any
religion at all so they kind of wanted
to go back to basics or at least like
from their perception I guess
so these nine family members who the
youngest one was nine years old
and the oldest one was 60 years old uh
and they all like legit like ran out and
jumped in front of a train and like
killed themselves they thought
that they would all return as Adam like
this pure being like with no ties to any
religion whatsoever like in their next
life I'm guessing and that's what would
I mean they really did seem to believe
that
now uh obviously after this happened
um the cops like you know even though
they jumped in front of a train they
didn't die in their house but they
actually did kind of like seal the house
which belonged to the family and that
house is now known as like the Adam
house and it's in uh this city in
Bangladesh which I'm sure I'm
pronouncing this wrong but it's called
something like that I'm sure I'm
pronouncing that wrong but it's you know
it's probably close enough uh so yeah so
they kind of closed it off but they call
it the Adam house now so if you put Adam
house suicide that's what comes up and
they said that like tons and tons of
people came out because they wanted to
see because the coffins and the graves
that they dug and [ __ ] like that were
still there so everybody thought that
was kind of cool so they wanted to like
go see it
so they asked so like I said they asked
around to like all the neighbors and was
like what's the deal with this like
religious cult thing that they started
now according to friends of theirs that
the guy that had died that like the
patriarch his name was Anwar Hussein uh
or sometimes he was called Anwar darbash
now he was like a retired army guy and
he died
um in July of 2000 like just regular
natural causes heart attack or something
like that like nothing nefarious or
anything
and um after that happened it seemed
like the family
kind of fell apart like they couldn't
really deal with it um they sort of like
completely isolated themselves they
didn't really talk to their relatives
anymore and you know just kind of like
went inward
and basically like they asked um the
guys like the guy that died like the
patriarch he had a younger brother he
was also a retired army and they asked
him about it and he's like yeah after my
brother died of a heart attack
um the family conver first converted to
Christianity and then they stopped
talking to everybody and if anybody went
there to like check on them they'd
basically like they said he said he they
behaved very badly like basically they
get away from us like we don't want
anything to do with you blah blah and in
the diary they basically said it was uh
written by the eldest son whose name was
Arif and he said well we converted to
Christianity but we haven't found any
peace or any solace in Christianity
and you know the local Christian
churches in the area said yeah they
never came here so you know they weren't
real that real into it and so they just
kind of started like I said they almost
started going to like kind of a
cafeteria thing like they were trying
out different things I guess because
they wanted to find some kind of piece
about their dad's death like they
couldn't deal with it and so they were
trying to find some belief system that
would make them feel better about it and
then they just kind of kept doing that
until they sort of went off the deep end
um apparently they didn't really believe
in any kind of traditional religion like
I said they even kind of went into Kali
worship for a little while but they
didn't they wanted to kind of like be
completely outside of religion and
apparently they didn't really know how
to do that so it's almost kind of like
they wanted to form their own thing uh
and so they started referring to
themselves as the Adam family because
like Adam and Eve you know what I mean
so in the diary like a reef actually
said they first tried to commit suicide
on uh July 7th 2007 which is 777 you
know obviously uh and they thought that
they would come back as Adam and then
they tried again on July 10th which was
actually the anniversary of the day that
their dad had died which they actually
observed every year they call that black
day so so yeah so that was like the
anniversary they tried to do it then but
I guess it like didn't work out and I
guess that was I don't know how they
tried to do it that day so obviously
they didn't jump a part of a train but
that was the day that they actually like
dug the graves in the yard and uh and
had the coffins and everything like that
but it didn't work for whatever reason
um it just I don't know it just kind of
like
uh the brother of the of the patriarch
that died he basically just said well I
don't know how much this has to do with
religion I think they were all just like
suffering from a mass mental illness
that's kind of what sounds like falia do
yeah yeah even though that's usually
just like two people but yeah it's like
an expanded like I said it's really
sounds like because I kind of feel like
and I don't you know no but I've heard
that in you know in India Bangladesh
like a place like that like a lot of
times you know there are a lot
traditionally they're a lot more like
family oriented so like if the patriarch
or The Matriarch or something like that
of the family dies
um then a lot of the other like family
members have a hard time dealing with
that and it really does seem like that's
kind of what happened it seemed like
they were so wrapped up in their dad and
this is again like a similar thing to
what happened in the next case that I'm
going to talk about which I have a lot
more details about but when they they
just didn't know what to do because like
the patriarch wasn't around anymore and
maybe he was like the head of the family
and they were used to deferring to him
or you know they were used to him being
there like for guidance or whatever and
then when he wasn't there anymore they
didn't really know what to do with
themselves and then you know then they
made it worse by like isolating
themselves so they only talked to one
another so it probably just like built
up into this [ __ ]
uh you know crazy belief system where
they just basically said well we just
we're gonna reincarnate and we're gonna
be completely free of religion and free
of
emotion or free of sadness about it or
whatever it just kind of seems like
that's what happened it's funny the
oldest son couldn't take over
yeah huh how old was the oldest son I'm
not sure actually
what happens yeah yeah that's yeah
that's traditionally that's what they
would do
it sounds like
yeah fully I do falia do yeah it's
that's usually two yeah Madness shared
by a team Madness shared by two which
sometimes it happens a lot with uh twins
twins Drive each other crazy and they
got this [ __ ] on video
two twin females out in the middle of
the Dead freeway yeah trying to throw
themselves in front of cars for no real
reason
they just start going crazy and the
influence that they have over each other
causes some kind of weird feedback
system where they just [ __ ] go crazy
it sounds like something like that
yeah it seems like that's kind of what
the what the relative thought like what
the brother thought he just thought that
they
like I said yeah it kind of happens and
like I said I reviewed the movie bug not
too long ago and that's kind of like
about that too where it's like your
craziness can like rub off on another
person if you don't have like any other
outside
sources you know what I'm saying so I
kind of feel like that's what happened
here because they definitely like
isolated themselves in one house and you
know they were
really getting like all into this
religious belief thing and they were
trying you know they they converted like
to a different religion which probably
like stressful and then it's like well
this isn't really working out either
like the way we hoped and
you know and then they just kind of like
when like I said went off the deep end
so much that they jumped in front of a
[ __ ] train I just can't believe that
they got
you would think that at least there
would be one you know dissenter in there
I mean because that's a big age range I
mean the youngest kid being nine years
old that's a nine-year-old kid and then
the oldest member of the family being 60
years old you would think that one of
them in there or at least like the kid
or something be like yeah I don't want
to do that but they all needed but they
shut the set down probably maybe and uh
guilted him out of it that's [ __ ] up
though
that's really [ __ ] up
maybe they were all just Edge Lords
Maybe
uh yeah but it's like adults though with
children it's just doing with their
parents or Elder siblings tell them to
yeah so maybe that's why yeah maybe it's
not as surprising that like the
nine-year-old kid went along with it I
was kind of thinking more I don't know
how old the other ones were because like
I said there's not a huge amount of
information about this one and it
basically says well the youngest one was
nine and the oldest one was was 60. so I
don't know like what the Ages were of
the other ones in between but
you know I I would have thought that
there would have been been at least one
person that was just like no I'm not
doing that especially something as like
horrific as jumping in front of a train
I mean
I I don't know I don't know what you I
don't know what you could do to like
convince me to do that [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying that's I can't really
think of anything at all like that would
convince me to do that so there so
there's that
so there's that uh but yeah so like I
said not a huge amount about that case
but uh somebody mentioned it a long time
ago and it was kind of similar to this
other one so I thought that I would
mention it here uh but then we're gonna
get into this other case the berrari
dust which is a lot better known and
like I said there was if you weren't
here earlier there's actually a Netflix
uh mini series documentary series about
it which is called House of Secrets and
I watched like some of it I didn't have
time to watch the whole thing but I
watched like the first couple episodes
of it and uh it's actually pretty good
it's like really uh in depth but Mark's
talking about his AMC Eagle now AMC is
long gone dude
remember the AMC they had to javelin
yeah
yeah I kind of remember EMC yeah they
weren't around for very long
they weren't bad cars then they wouldn't
they make one call a Pacer I think so
yeah no yeah I think they did make the
Pacer
you were around for a little I thought I
knew somebody that had one of those
my favorite car that they made was uh
was the javelin back late 70s Chaplin
yeah the javelin was like their answer
to the Mustang it was like this thing
I'm like Sharp
it's got like their version of two
two-door [ __ ] sports coupe
Coupe that's British
yeah I'm like pretty sure I mean I guess
like over there that it does have like
the accent on it but yeah it doesn't
have the accent on it over here so I'll
say it like that
but I have heard him say it like that
over there because I'm like hey what the
[ __ ] is that yeah but they're closer to
France so they have an exclusive
hell they call an eggplant an aubergine
so yeah aubergine aubergine [ __ ]
eggplant
well it's funny because like I said I
was watching um there's a really good
Channel called Lost in the pond and it's
like a guy he's like a British guy but
he's lived in the U.S like in the
Midwest for like 14 15 years and he's
married to an American woman and uh he's
always doing videos about
different words like that he never heard
before he moved over here and he's like
yeah he didn't know what an eggplant was
because they don't call it an eggplant
it's the same thing but they call it an
aubergine so I just I just thought that
was really funny that he didn't know
he's like eggplant where the [ __ ] they
call it that it doesn't make any sense I
don't know why they call it an eggplant
either yeah it doesn't look like an egg
it doesn't taste like an egg
they call they call cilantro [ __ ] um
coriander they do yeah
they do
isn't coriander like C
implant yeah I think so I think it's the
same well you got coriander seeds but
then they have coriander right coriander
is cilantro yeah
it is very confusing everybody kind of
knows about the biscuit cookie yeah
biscuit cookies dilemma jelly and Jello
actually the biscuit cookie thing they
recently did that in like a Geico
commercial where like the little the
little gecko like brings these like
homemade biscuits and he's like ooh
cookies and he's like biscuits
even though I thought they were actual
yeah you asked for a biscuit here in the
United States you're not gonna get if
you're British you gotta do you have a
biscuit let me have some biscuits what
they're gonna bring you you're not gonna
recognize it's like why would it be why
is this like a scone except it's not
yeah a biscuit is a [ __ ] scone and
it's not sweet
and they put and they put sausage gravy
on it yeah it's just self-rising it's
self-rising flour and [ __ ] shortening
all right made a little bit of water
that's a biscuit or you go to KFC they
put like a big hunk of fried chicken
they're good they're real good but
they're they're nothing like a cookie
okay yeah cookies are completely
different cookies
flour sugar and eggs with [ __ ]
vanilla
that's good and then you put well
there's all different kind of cookies
yeah but most cookies are good I'm not a
mineral as flour is sugar with butter
that's it
that's like sugar cookies
everything is a sugar cookie you just
modify off that base to turn it into a
chocolate chip cookie or a peanut butter
cookie but it's that same base or a
snickerdoodle or a snickerdoodle or you
know it's that same base it's just sugar
flour and eggs
butter
Rebecca said Australia is a mix of the
English English and American and our own
made-up words usually swearing yeah
Australia is kind of like half it it's
like halfway in between the United
States and UK in terms of the language
it's it sounds a little bit English to
us sometimes but it's also real American
in a way too
you guys aren't that you know you guys
are not as bad as the British
I'm really I really
that like English and Australia like
their slang words are a lot more
creative yeah you know what I mean
I really like a lot of their slangs I'm
really I'm really into like Bruce like
some American American slang's gotten
better like since the internet age but I
don't know it's not as clever I feel
like it's not as clever it doesn't sound
as cool yeah but now the British are
cool too I was like [ __ ] with you
like [ __ ] with them yeah the closest
thing to
the UK that we never have been New
England that would be around the
Massachusetts area
Boston type area that's kind of like
something you'd find out of the UK but
the rest of the United States is nothing
like that I lived I lived in
Massachusetts I loved it
for a while
[Music]
for me it's the South I like the South
that's just
fits my personality more
yeah Danny Rowling's asking about what a
Sheila is I thought Sheila was just like
a girl like like if you were in the UK
and you said like a bird that's the same
thing as like just saying like a girl
like a chick yeah you know what I mean
yeah that's what Ben said it just means
a woman that's what I thought yeah I
didn't think it was like derogatory
necessarily it's like oh let's go pick
up some Sheilas it's like calling Santa
Joe
is just a dude
like a although nobody nobody just calls
people a Joe you can say an average Joe
or a working Joe GI Joe or GI Joe but
I've never I've never heard people just
like refer to a bunch of guys as Joe's
well it's out of date yeah but maybe
they used to I think 50s if Joe was a
dude nowadays it's just yeah a bunch of
guys are a bunch of dudes and honestly
like even nowadays I don't know about
the England and Australia but in the US
I kind of feel like guys has almost
become like a non-gender term like he's
like yeah you guys like that's just
everybody that's like mixed that's men
women whatever that's everybody you guys
yeah
Latin language that just people says
which means like y'all yeah y'all yeah I
mean that's what they say themselves
y'all you are yeah
or use guys that's a yeah that's the
northern equivalent yeah you use guys
use guys that's Yankees [ __ ] it is yeah
but yeah we just stay y'all down here
yeah yeah yeah or dude I kind of feel
like dude is almost non-gendered too
because people are just well people use
dude in a lot of different ways too it
doesn't just necessarily mean like a
person it could mean it could be like an
exclamation like dude you know what I
mean like that's [ __ ] up so
it's you know it's a versatile it's
versatile word
Rebecca said uh Sheila means in today's
Times Like a strong-willed bossy female
oh okay so not necessarily a chick
the boss girl girl boss yeah like girl
boss or you know boss girl
but they no I mean girl boss is an
actual yeah phrase yeah it's not so much
the other way around okay
um let's see anybody remember the Danish
Christmas sugar cookies that came in a
round 10 container they still make those
yeah they sell [ __ ] like crazy here
they still make those it's a tradition
we buy them every year yeah we get it
yeah oh good the danish cookies I think
I don't know if we got any last
Christmas but we got some that Christmas
before coming a little wax paper [ __ ]
cups yeah stacked in there different
kinds they're funny because they're like
all like all of them are different
shapes but they all taste like pretty
much exactly there are some differences
some of them taste like they have
coconut in them yeah so and then some of
them are like a little bit thinner and
crunchier but like most of them pretty
much some have big sugar crystals on the
top
yeah and uh they're great dog to cook in
coffee yeah they're because they're not
like super super sweet and they don't
have like icing on them or nothing like
that they're just like very much they're
not shortbread they remind me they're
reminding me we're gonna have to get
some they got them at Sam's about twenty
dollars a car a tin they're like a big
huge tip yeah that big that big and that
usually takes like a while for us to go
through you get extras
go there when Christmas is over and
they'll have them things on [ __ ]
discount you get them for half price
well yeah what do you think like all the
people do like the day after Halloween
they go there and stuff stuck up on all
the Halloween candy it's always
happening and they'll be good in that
tent for six months easy yeah they keep
her a long time they keep a long time
because like I said usually we'll get
some and then we'll get some extra but
then like we get sick of food like over
the holidays but then like if you open
it like a few months later like they're
still good they won't go steel as long
as you don't kind of like you know open
them up and PAW around in there you know
what I mean
well they come silver plastic as long as
that plastic seal is they're probably
good for a year if you didn't break that
plastic seal yeah I don't imagine that
they would they would go back and even
if they were a little bit stale big deal
like you just you put them in coffee dip
them in coffee it's fine it's not gonna
hurt you uh no I got everything to make
cookies
you you know what you say that all the
time but you never make that I got so
much [ __ ] butter down there and I got
so I gotta [ __ ] I thought you had
like all that oatmeal yeah I got two or
three pounds cookies and chocolate chips
I got everything well [ __ ] you can make
oatmeal cookies with chocolate chips you
can make peanut butter cookies all that
peanut butter right here you can make
peanut butter cookies
he says this all the time and like
teases me but he never I've made [ __ ]
peanut butter cookies
one time and put them inside a [ __ ]
a [ __ ] uh cupcake cupcake pan yeah
we'll put that in there so they were
actually no it was an oatmeal cookie
put him in no it's peanut butter is it
peanut butter yeah and then I put
Nutella in it yeah well I mean you baked
them and then yeah and then they baked
them and I put Nutella in it and I think
I put [ __ ] I think I put [ __ ] um
uh uh peanut butter on top of that
didn't I and pulled them or was it just
Nutella no it was just that's just
Nutella and we were pulling them out of
there like they were cupcakes and eating
them and it was it was [ __ ] super
good I mean you could really only eat
one but yeah
because they were probably like real
Rich 2 000 calories real rich I mean
they weren't huge they were just they
were like that that size of a cupcake
but they were very very I mean they
weren't quite as big as a cupcake I
think they were like a little bit
Nutella would solidify in there well
they put them in we put them in the
fridge yeah like so then that's how I
would get salad yeah so it was like
eating fudge fudge inside a peanut
butter cookie fudge yeah
yeah Jeffy art said I love the Danish
butter cookies 20 pounds of weight gain
in a tin yeah probably and then Ben said
Scottish shortbread is the best I love
love love shortbread cookies I love
shortbread cookies honestly like I don't
even know if they make them here anymore
but for a while like when I was a kid I
used to really like those uh Lorna Dunes
oh yeah which are like shortbread that
was like the mass market like I haven't
made cocoons in a long time yeah yeah I
mean well you know holiday holidays are
coming up yeah I got all that I got all
that you can eat all the things I'll go
over that pumpkin meat down there Frozen
too and those other pumpkins that I
could cook can make a pumpkin pie
yeah make the bucket or a pumpkin
cookies remember we said we were gonna
make pumpkin cookies and we never did
forgot about that we made pumpkin bread
and soup and yeah I mean he made a
really nice like pump like a Thai
pumpkin soup the other day that was
really really good you're gonna put
chicken in it put it on Rice like it was
[ __ ] like it was uh Curry it was good
yeah it was really
yeah okay let's get back to the show
wait a minute Danny rolling said uh
Chips Ahoy and Pepperidge Farm cookies
are the best uh store-bought anyway yeah
um the Pepperidge Farm I like the
Chessmen and probably like the mint
Milanos I like Moana I'm gonna disagree
with all y'all
they're two best cookies
Sunshine [ __ ] lemon coolers I haven't
seen them in a long time yeah those are
good Sunshine brand I don't think they
exists anymore it was like a sugar
cookie with lemon
lemon chips in it they're instead of
chocolate chips they were lemon flavored
and then they were covered in powdered
sugar and Britain they would call that
[ __ ] icing sugar
man those things are super good super
good I remember those if you put them in
the microwave just for a few seconds
just just to kind of warm them up they
got a little bit soft and they were real
good
and the uh
I'm gonna kind of steam the icing sugar
on the outside of it so they get a
little so it'd stick to it another one
that was good was [ __ ] I'm going to
say that you know
[ __ ] those peanut butter cookies what
were they Nutter butter
yeah I [ __ ] love I mean pretty much
it's hard to pick like I mean I
I I would be hard-pressed to like turn
down pretty much any cookie yeah I'm not
a big fan of like Fig Newtons I don't
love those like if that was all there
was I'd eat them like they're not
terrible but they're not my favorite a
bunch of different flavors now they do
yeah they don't like them all I mean the
strawberry ones are good I do like the
strawberries pineapple ones blueberry
and fig the Fig's good
you put them in the microwave for a few
seconds it totally changes the dynamic I
don't really like soft cookies that much
easier other than those ones they sell
at Walmart that are kind of like that
are almost kind of like cake yeah like
you know what I'm talking about they
sell they're like that big and they kind
of have uh icing on the top those are
good
um and sometimes like fresh cookies like
if you make chocolate chip cookies and
they're you know when they're out of the
oven and they're soft they're good like
that but normally I kind of like a more
crunchy cookie I like it to have like a
little bit of bite to it like not be
squishy like a cake I mean I'm not
saying I don't like cake because I do
but in a cookie I'd rather have a little
bit crunchy yeah and Camp guys talk
about uh pecan sandies oh yeah oh those
are delicious I love those yeah because
that's shortbread with pecans in it yeah
those are really good I like those a lot
I haven't had those in a long time now
that same company made chili Donuts no
it was Dolly Madison remember they had
the raspberry
jelly donuts remember those things yeah
what were they called
I don't remember they came in a little
box
they were Donuts
they were powdered sugar on the outside
and in the middle it was it was
raspberry jam man those things were
[ __ ] good I forgot what they were
called I know what you're talking about
but I can't remember oh man you just put
them in the microwave just for like
[ __ ] five seconds just to kind of
make them a little bit more fresh
tasting so they weren't cold they would
get a little Airy and man those things
were so [ __ ] good
these ethos with those pecan sandies
Jeff yard said every every Christmas my
sister makes pumpkin dream cookies with
walnuts or pecans white chocolate chips
and cinnamon icing
yeah that sounds delicious we're getting
we're getting the audience fat and the
audience is getting us fat talking about
this sure I know I'm gonna I'm getting
fat as we thank you go ahead you want
another uh yeah yeah yeah and then Danny
Rowling said shoot uh chewy Chips Ahoy
with ice cream in the middle is banging
yeah I agree with that although I kind
of like the crunchy one because I like
the I like the um you know combination
of textures there but the soft ones are
good too actually the chewy Chips Ahoy
are like pretty good as far as like
chewing I remember they did like a whole
thing aren't they weren't there cookies
called didn't they have a thing called
Soft batch I don't know if they make
those anymore soft batch that sounds
kind of dirty but you know
that Rebecca said I'm getting high not
fat
Mark says I'm still a fan of the one
dollar cherry or apple pies yeah I mean
they're still good all that stuff is
still good I used to like like I said I
used to like I think they were Dolly
Madison but I used to like the um little
chocolate pudding pies I liked I liked
those you know but I don't know if they
make those anymore
not like I'm out looking for that kind
of stuff because if I have it in the
house I'll totally eat it so I try not
to so I try not to buy [ __ ] like that
all right so um yeah well here's the
thing okay so let me just like talk
about this other case and then because
it seems like we're just like gonna be
talking about food all day and I feel
kind of bad because this is like a
really like terrible
scary case but yeah so we'll talk about
this and then maybe after that we can
talk about food because I feel kind of
bad
um yeah Sarah said I was raised to bake
we made like eight different kinds of
cookies every year that's what my
grandma liked my maternal Grandma I used
to used to do that before I mean she's
still alive but like before she got um
older and had a stroke she used to make
like a whole bunch of different kind of
cookies like for everybody and she would
make like all these bags like she put
all different kind of cookies like in
these little Ziploc bags and then she
put them all in Christmas bags and she'd
give everybody in the family one and my
mom's side of the family is like huge so
she would just like make just so many
cookies just hundreds and hundreds like
of all different kinds so
yeah Ben said tell us about the dead
children we could talk about gingerbread
later that's kind of like why does that
always happen why does it always happen
with this show it's like I feel kind of
bad but it's just like I don't know it
just it happens it happens
but yeah so um at least in this case
uh
I'm not saying this like they weren't
like little little kids you know what I
mean I mean they were still like
teenagers some of them were teenagers
which is still kind of [ __ ] up but
at least they weren't as young as nine
and they didn't jump in front of a train
because holy [ __ ] that's like [ __ ] up
but uh this case actually when somebody
recommended this to me I didn't realize
that it was this recent like this only
happened like a couple years ago this
happened in July of 2018.
um so what happens it's July 1st 2018.
thank you
and uh there's a guy who kind of lives
in this neighborhood in um in Delhi it's
like the berrari is like the area but I
guess it's like North Delhi which is in
India
so he's kind of on his daily walk like
he goes out for a walk every morning and
he always goes to this one particular
grocery store to you know buy his milk
for the day or whatever so he gets there
and the store isn't open
um and he thinks this is really unusual
because it's already like 7 15 in the
morning something like that and he's
like well the store always opened at six
in the morning like like clockwork it
was always open on time
so this guy that was walking by he
actually knew the owner because it's you
know they they lived in the neighborhood
and everybody kind of knew them uh so
the guy that owned the place was named
um boovnesh and he was you know a friend
of his and he just lived around the
corner so he called him on the phone
being like hey why is your store not
open but nobody answered so he said well
you know I'm just gonna pop around to
their house like the family's house and
see if everything's okay like see what's
going on
so a 7 15 he gets to the house and the
front door is unlocked again which is a
little unusual
so he's like and on the Netflix
documentary they interviewed the guy
that uh found it found all the stuff and
uh he's like yeah the door was unlocked
and open and he's like and I felt like a
lot of trepidation but he's like you
know I decided I was going to go in
there and check it out see what was
going on
so he starts walking up the stairs
because it looked like from what I could
see on the documentary it just looked
like there was kind of like a door like
a street level and then it was like
Steps like going up to the living area
so he goes in there and what he sees in
the documentary they didn't show the
whole entire
scene but they showed like parts of it
like that wasn't that wasn't too bad you
know what I mean it's like they didn't
like show you the whole thing like in
all its horrible Glory but they did kind
of like Show Bits of it so you could
kind of like imagine
so basically he walks in and he sees
10 bodies
hanging from this iron grid like there
was a ceiling and then there was like a
kind of an iron grid and there was like
a screen and I guess like it had some
kind of like thing like up on the roof
but in the picture like it wasn't there
but there were all these pipes like this
grid and the bodies were all hanging
from this Grid 10 of them
all of the bodies had tape over their
eyes and their mouths
most of them had their hands bound
behind their backs uh most of them with
um phone cords like phone wire stuff
like that
and some of them uh particularly the
children the um teenagers had their feet
bound together also
uh the family's dog whose name was Tommy
was actually tied to the same grid but
was on the roof and was actually alive
and was like barking his head off
because obviously you know he's like
what the [ __ ] like he was up on the roof
you know what I mean but he was tied to
the same thing
because it was like it's hard for me to
explain but there was there was like a
grid and then there was like a mesh and
then it was like open you know what I
mean but I think normally there was
something that they would put over this
opening that was kind of like up on the
roof but it wasn't there like in the
picture so it was just like open to this
did they mean to hang the dog
I don't think they did I think the dog
was just like on a leash okay because
the the dog was outside was like on the
roof these were they were inside they
were in the living room you know what I
mean yeah
so um so yeah so obviously this guy
who's like a friend of the family he
sees he's like holy [ __ ] this is like
the [ __ ] most [ __ ] up thing he's
ever seen and so he runs outside and he
calls the cops now the first cop to come
there whose name was uh Rajiv tomar and
he was also interviewed on the
documentary
he said I mean he'd been on the forest
like he said at 17 years at this point
and he's like I had never seen anything
like this this was just like there's
like a [ __ ] horror movie like all
these [ __ ] bodies just like lace lit
hanging there like that now initially
they thought that this was a murder like
a mass murder you know what I mean they
were like well we couldn't really think
how that might have happened but you
know we didn't really know what to think
it's like we never seen anything like
this you know what I mean so they were
like we were just like at a loss
so all of the dead people
uh belong to one family even though this
is called like the berrari deaths or
sometimes I say called the Ferrari
family their name wasn't that that was
the that was like the section of the
town where they were found was called
berari from uh New Delhi their last name
was actually uh chundawage that was
their family that was their family name
so the family was actually it was like
two men six women and two teenagers
that's who they found now the ten bodies
that they found hanging on the first
floor of the house and they were like in
kind of like a circular formation like I
said they did show photos of the crime
scene but not entirely like they didn't
show their faces or anything like that
so it's disturbing but it's like not
disturbing as it could have been
oh pokey's making
what's up Pokey you're walking around
trying to get attention yeah like she at
least she's not yelling she's being
pretty she was yelling earlier yeah I
heard her yeah but I guess because the
fan we turned the fan on early so she
wouldn't get she's making like their
little ears are like yeah
she's trying to get involved she's like
watching trying to get involved huh yeah
there's you see yeah she's like okay
yeah I don't know that's enough of that
so yeah so the 10 bodies that they found
belong to like I said all one family uh
you had both Nash uh bubnesh Singh who
was 50. his wife Savita was 48 and there
are three kids uh nitu who was 25 menaka
she was 23 and dhruv who was 15. then
you had uh lalit who was 45 and he was
actually both Nash's brother his wife
Tina who was 42 and they had a 15 year
old son named Shivam uh he was there
also then there was uh
um
above Nash's sister whose name was uh
pratiba I think is how you pronounce it
and she had a 33 year old daughter whose
name whose name was uh Priyanka now
there was another family member who was
the mother of bhuvnesh and lalit and she
was 80 years old and she was named
nariani Debbie now she was actually the
only one that wasn't found hanging she
was found dead on the floor like in
another room like an adjacent room and
she actually had like a scarf around her
neck
and there was like a kind of a
suspicious Mark like she had been
strangled you know what I mean well yeah
we'll get into like what happened with
that but yeah they found her like in the
other room like laying face down again
in the documentary they do show crime
scene photos but a lot of them are kind
of like blurred out so they're
disturbing but they're not like super
super maybe she wasn't strong enough to
get up on that rack maybe she killed
herself well yeah like I said they they
got into they figured out what happened
but like they didn't know at first yeah
so this particular family this is like
crazy so this family had migrated um to
Delhi from uh a place called Rajasthan
Rajasthan I'm sure I'm pronouncing all
these names wrong so forgive me like
anybody from India same move I think
they had been Farmers uh previously but
they'd moved in the 1990s now from what
I could gather this is kind of like what
they said I don't know like I thought
what they said was that Tina and lalit
had only had either only just got
married or they had just announced the
engagement of one of their you know kids
or one of the daughters or something
like that because they said like two
weeks before this event they'd actually
like had this big like wedding or
engagement party like at the same place
like and there was video of it like that
was on the documentary and everybody was
just like dancing and having a good time
and everybody just said everything was
completely normal and they just how long
ago was this 2018. no I'm saying it was
how many months before the the bodies
were found two weeks two weeks
actually maybe not even that long
because I one of them said 10 days but
then one of them said 14 days but I
don't know but they just had like some
kind of big it was either a wedding or
an engagement party
and it says if they're planning for the
future and they spent right and they
spent all this money like having this
big shindig and they said all the
neighbors and all their relatives came
over and they said everything was normal
and everybody was like having a good
time uh so yeah it was like kind of
weird but that had happened like about
two weeks like prior to like them all
being found dead
so now this family actually owned like I
said this grocery store it's kind of
like a grocery General Store type of
situation and they also had like a
plywood store like they you know they
cut wood and things like that
so the police come in there and they
interviewed like a lot of the cops that
have been on the scene that you know uh
you know were on the investigation and
everything and they were just like
completely baffled they had no [ __ ]
idea they had never seen anything like
this
um they looked into every single like
family member they're like you know what
was it was it like a business rival was
it like some kind of romantic jealousy
situation was it some kind of property
dispute was it some what was it like
nobody actually knew anything like
nobody seemed to dislike these people at
all and actually in the documentary they
interviewed like a bunch of their like
friends and neighbors and relatives and
stuff like that everybody that lived on
the street knew them I mean they they
owned like the the grocery the main
grocery store like on this in this
neighborhood and like so like everybody
knew them and most of their neighbors
were just like they were lovely
delightful people it's like they babysat
our kids like you know we went over
their house all the time it's like they
were just really really nice people and
so they were just like flipping out they
have no they had no idea like why
because like said at first they kind of
thought they had been murdered right
some kind of Honor suicide we'll see but
yeah so the cops are like investigating
and they're like again like I said at
first they're thinking it's a murder but
then they were like well okay they're
like for one thing no sign of four
century right um looked like nothing was
taken like you know some of the even the
women that were hanging there they still
had like expensive jewelry and stuff
like that nothing was stolen out of
there uh there didn't look like there
was any struggle inside the house at all
you know uh of any kind so nothing now a
lot of the locals did actually kind of
believe that it was murder uh because
they knew the family and they're like oh
they would never kill themselves uh you
know because they were just acting
regular so they thought a lot of the
locals kind of thought because they
talked to some of the cops about it too
because the cops were like yeah the
locals really didn't like us all that
much uh they were actually kind of like
accusing the cops of like mishandling
the case or covering up evidence that it
was a murder like [ __ ] like that so
there's there was a lot of like um
kind of contentious like feeling between
the locals and the cops at the time but
the cops on there were just like look we
we didn't know what was going on either
we were just trying to figure out what
was going on so we were just not ruling
anything out you know what I mean they
weren't you know they were they were
trying to do their best
now interestingly the the one guy the 50
year old guy above Nash he actually
looked as though he had attempted to
untie himself like one of his hands was
free and you know he was dead obviously
but like his hand was and they did show
a picture of it like his hand was like
on the knot like around his neck like
almost like he changed his mind or
something and he was like trying to like
uh you know kind of get it off uh cops
did find a the remains of a little like
ritual pyre like on the floor of the
home it was like a little uh it looked
like kind of like a little cauldron
except it was kind of like Square it was
like a little cauldron walk kind of
situation something that you would like
burn incense in or like make a little
offering type of thing like in front of
your little Temple or your Shrine or
whatever uh so they did find that and
they were like well that's a little
unusual
uh you know that they were doing that
like that night
so the cops
um they start looking through the CCTV
footage because they're you know this
was like a busy street so there were
CCTV cameras that were like right near
the entrance to their house so they're
like okay well if somebody came in there
and killed all of them then obviously
the CCTV camera will pick up like any
suspicious kind of person
so they said we sat there and we went
through the thing like frame by frame
like looking for anything weird now they
didn't see any suspicious people or
anybody going in there that shouldn't
but one thing that they did see was a
bunch of the various family members
purchasing
stools new stools from the market and
also they watched them buying some of
the scarves that they would later be
hanged with like they saw them like
going to and like the 15 year old kids
were doing that like they went to the
market and they would come back with the
scarves that later on they were hanging
from and they said we didn't see anybody
unusual like going because the CCTV
camera you can see very clearly like the
front of their house they're all
planning it out yeah so at that point
they were like holy [ __ ] they're like
either one family member or a couple of
the family members conspired and killed
the other ones or all of them were in on
this together and they planned it out
because obviously they bought stools and
scarves and stuff like that to do this
with and like I said they found um you
know the little pyre thing too almost
like they were giving an offering like
beforehand so they're like they thought
that was pretty weird too
they also notice they don't know if
there was anything to this but they said
they noticed in some of the photos and
then they went back to look at it like
of the outside of the house
there was like this really weird pattern
of pipes like on the outside of the
house like do you know the outside wall
and there were these little pipes like
sticking out which was weird they were
like we don't know why those were there
like some of them would come like
straight out and then some of them were
like curved so they were like facing
downward
and they're like that's really weird
like why why do they have those pipes
like popping out the wall like of their
house and then they realized that
um some of the pipes were straight and
some of them were facing down and the
straight and facing down ones like
corresponded to seven women and four men
like who had died and the pipes they
said if you turned the picture like on
its side were in the same configuration
as the hanging bodies had been
there are pipes coming out of the wall
out of the wall like it's not like far
out but just like a couple inches like
sticking out like that and some of them
like stuck out straight yeah and then
some of them were like like that like
pointed down you know what I mean yeah
and they were just they looked it looked
like random yeah but they said like when
they you know took a picture of it and
then turned the picture on its side they
said it looked just like the
configuration of the people like the way
they were hanging like in the same
pattern you know what I mean
so what are we implying here well see
that's what they were trying to figure
out because they noticed that and it was
weird and then they said well
is
is there some reason like did they think
that like those pipes were gonna help
their souls Escape or something like
that because they said they'd call the
contractor specifically to have those
pipes put in and the family told them
it's like oh it's just for extra
ventilation
and they were like yeah but putting a
little pipe in the wall like that's not
really ventilation like what the [ __ ]
does that even mean and so they weren't
really sure and then the contractor
later said oh it was just random like we
just put them in the walls randomly and
like some of them were curved and one of
them some were straight and we didn't
think about it but they just thought
that it was really weird that like the
pattern of it like looked the same so
they kind of like made a big deal about
that like they had been planning to
and there was a lot of other stuff too
about because there was 11 of them that
killed themselves they there was a lot
of stuff like that came out of the media
like how there was we like things in
their house that had to do with the
number 11 and maybe they thought that
that was like had some kind of like
numerical significance or something like
that so there was a lot of that kind of
stuff but some people thought maybe they
put those pipes there because they
thought it would like help their souls
Escape or something like that like they
would each have one or something like
that sounds like the damn [ __ ]
pyramids of Egypt in Giza where they got
the dam
shafts that lead to the stars going
through the pyramid but probably nothing
to it
yeah they were kind of like
um they were kind of like two sides on
that because sometimes the cops were
like well that's pretty weird though
it's like in the same pattern and it
seems like they didn't really know like
why they had those put there but then
like some of the other like journalists
and like the contractor and stuff was
like nah it was just random we just
stuck them in the wall because they
asked them to ask them to but I don't
know what their reasoning was because it
didn't look like
it didn't look like it had really any
function
like why would you just like poke holes
in like the outside of your wall like it
wasn't it wasn't on the ground floor it
was like on the on the second floor of
the first floor whatever where they were
hanging no it was it was from the same
room yeah I think it looked like the
house like I said the house
because they came they kept saying first
floor but
anywhere other than the United States
that usually means what we would call
the second floor because the ramp they
called the ground floor and then the
first floor but right over here we call
it the second floor because the first
floor is the ground floor but I thought
like the living quarters where they were
found was the first floor or in America
maybe maybe they're true maybe they're
telling the truth for ventilation maybe
they thought
they'd be hanging there for a long time
for a while stink in the place that's
kind of what I thought and they wanted
the smell to leave the house either to
tell people that they were that they
were there or they wanted to get the
smell to leave the house or the house
well I kind of thought that too but then
like as I read more about it and I read
what their intentions were yeah should I
spoil it no go ahead good okay I'm just
I'm not sure good I'm not sure that's
why I'm not sure that's why all right
so while they're going through so yes it
was the whole pipe thing now while they
were going through the house like
looking for Clues they found a diary
like a handwritten diary like a notebook
and they found it near like the um the
temple altar like in the house
and then when they were looking around
they found like another Diary in another
room that was like in the same
handwriting now these Diaries actually
stretched from they had started writing
in them from in 2007 and the entries
went all the way up to 2018 which is
like right before the deaths
now the Diaries were actually written by
lalit who was the you know the son who
was 45 and he was kind of like the guy
that
I don't know if he was necessarily like
the orchestrator but this is apparently
what happened
so lalit was
um originally I guess he was like a
medical student but he got some kind of
like illness and he couldn't like go to
school anymore so he had to drop out and
then he ended up working at uh a plot
the plywood shop you know what I mean he
worked there until
um from like the 90s to like 2008. now
at his work in 2004 there was kind of
like this accident and there was like a
big fire and he was trapped in it and he
actually ended up like losing his voice
and they don't know if it was like
psychological or if it was like some
actual like damage that was in there or
I don't know that like I couldn't find
like any Source on that because like I
said this there's stuff about this but a
lot of it's not in English
so but he didn't really talk all that
much
um so basically this is kind of the same
situation as what happened with the
Adams House lalit's Father uh whose name
was uh bopal Singh he was kind of like a
really really
um beloved dude like in the community
like everybody called him daddy pretty
much which kind of sounds dirty but I
guess it's like it's fine over there I'm
just saying it's just kind of like it
sounds kind of dirty from our point of
view
um but yeah he was kind of one of those
guys everybody in the neighborhood knew
him he would always help you out blah
blah blah
um and his wife was actually the the
older woman that they would find dead
like later on
now he actually died suddenly uh from a
respiratory illness in 2006.
and it seems that after that again the
family kind of started falling apart a
little bit because you know this was
like their their patriarch their father
figure and now he wasn't there anymore
so the family gets together and they do
this big long like 10-day ceremony Like
a Prayer like for his soul or whatever
during this 10-day ceremony lolit
started talking like chanting and like I
said remember he like sensed the fire
like in 2004 he hadn't talked so they
thought it was like a miracle you know
what I mean that um you know that he was
talking now and they got the idea that
Lola's father was actually talking
through him was like communicating with
them
so you know because he hadn't talked in
three years and now suddenly he's
talking uh while they're doing the
prayer for the dead dad
so um so lalit he says yeah it's like
it's a miracle it's the dead father he's
like inside he's like speaking through
me and he said that he had appeared in
his dreams and told him to do this whole
ceremony
so the family who were um their
neighbors said that they you know they
were really really nice and everything
but they said they were kind of like
superstitious you know what I mean they
were very superstitious
so basically they believed that lalit
had become a medium essentially and that
he was channeling messages from their
dad
um so basically what happened was that
lolit
started getting more into like
mediumship and the Occult and everything
like that and started keeping a diary in
2007 like a few months after his dad
died
and in this diary
he started writing out supposed messages
from his dad that was telling the entire
family like what they were supposed to
be doing and this was like supposed to
be messages from him right and they were
very very strict like every single thing
in their lives was like regulated now
because Dad says that you have to do
this that and the other thing like your
diet your everything and he had like
advice for everybody right ridiculous
yeah reading the [ __ ] like I said Watch
the documentary it's fascinating but
like some of the [ __ ] that like is
written in there it's just like do you
think dude believed this or do you think
he's they all seem to believe it no the
medium the guy who's the medium no I
don't know or is he just you sir is he
becoming the leader of the family
it could have been that but like I said
it's I mean
every bit they all did seem to believe
it I kind of thought like some of the
stuff that he wrote in there was a
little bit I'm gonna say it was very
self-serving like uh particularly like
him and his wife Tina like basically oh
well they're the good ones and you guys
should do like what they tell you and
like Vietnam all your money and right
like so it was that kind of like Vibe
like some of the messages so I'm not
really sure how aware he was of how he
was manipulating the rest of his family
um or if he genuinely did believe that
his father was talking through him it
could go either way it's kind of hard to
say I haven't read the whole diary
obviously it could be a mixture of the
two it could have just been that he did
actually believe it was Dad talking to
him and it just happened that maybe he
wasn't completely aware that he was just
making everything like really
you know like I said it was like very
self-serving like oh me and Tina are the
good ones you guys should like listen to
everything we say blah blah blah but
yeah so everything that's in these
Diaries like from 2007 up until 2018 are
these really really strict routines for
every single member of the family
because it was like three generations
that lived in one house like in this
kind of like four room house or whatever
and yes it was like a daily routine like
what every single person had to do
um and you know what was going to give
them success or whatever
um and some of it like I said had to do
with diet like they stopped eating meat
altogether because some of them had not
been vegetarian prior but they all
became vegetarians after
um they all of them stopped drinking
alcohol like a couple of them had you
know had had a drink every now and then
but they all uh completely stopped uh
and because they followed the rules
supposedly like for a little while
um I guess
they um their business actually started
doing really well because like I said
they had
um you know they had the store and it
started like getting better and they
started getting like a lot more money
like coming in
and their neighbors speculated uh their
neighbors and like extended family
speculated that because they had success
in business not long after they started
following these tenants
um they probably believed that that was
the dad's Spirit like rewarding them for
doing what he told them you know what I
mean they said so it just it reinforced
itself they were doing what daddy said
to do and their business was getting
better and like things were getting
better and they said that like the
younger women were like really doing
well in school they all got jobs so
everything was like seeming like it was
going at a really successful Direction
and so they probably perceived that as
being rewarded for following the rules
that lalit was laying out and saying was
coming from their dad you know what I
mean uh because he was like Daddy was
like sending them like guidance from the
other side is basically what they seem
to believe
okay Pokey you settle down she's down
there calling all right people please uh
like share subscribe and uh if you
[ __ ] uh enjoy the show please send us
a super chat if you can afford it if not
don't worry about it just go ahead I'm
plugging the show because I could
yeah Ben says imagine living a Frugal
and healthy lifestyle without drinking
can lead to business being better yeah
and the thing about it is that some of
the stuff might have just been
coincidence I mean the like I said the
younger girls like for they were in
their 20s and they were about the you
know time when they would be graduating
from college and you know getting jobs
and things like that so I think it was
just kind of like coincidental that
everything seemed like it was looking up
like not too long after lalit started
like laying out all these rules for them
but they seem to like
to whatever like I said I wasn't there
so I don't know like how the
conversations went down but they
apparently did believe that doing what
daddy told them to do through wallet was
causing them to be successful so that
made them want to keep doing it because
you had to think like this has been
going this went on for a long time he
started doing the Diaries in 2007 and
they didn't actually like kill
themselves until 2018. so it was like 11
years and he filled up like a diary like
each year so they did actually end up I
think finding like 11 Diaries of his so
you know every year he had like all
these new things that he was supposed to
do like they had things that they were
supposed to do every day
now a week before they found their
bodies uh when they went through like uh
the last pages of the last Diary they
discovered what they were looking for
they they had very meticulously planned
this out and it was a whole ritual they
called it the Banyan Tree ritual and the
reason it was called that um and it's
funny because they said the cops that
came in there when they first saw the
scene they said yeah it looked like a
banyan tree like the way they were
hanging there which if you don't know
it's like a tree that has like roots
that like hang down from the branches
like that
and that's uh apparently exactly what
they were going for like that's what
they wanted it to look like
so um so this ritual they wanted it they
said basically they wanted themselves to
like hang like looking like the branches
of a banyan tree like in a circular
formation and they thought that this was
going to give them salvation you know
what I mean and like I said the diary
laid out every single step of like
everything they had to do like all the
stuff they had to buy like the way they
had to like tie people up the way they
had to do everything
um you know the way that the knots had
to be tied all this other kind of stuff
what they and this was like I said it
was all written out so it's like there
was no mystery anymore
basically what they did was lalit and
his wife Tina uh they were the ones that
blindfolded all the family members and
tied all their legs together and then
they put cotton in their ears
and then they taped their mouths closed
and then they wrapped their faces in
like uh bed sheets like they tore up a
bed sheet and like tore and um you know
covered all their faces up with that
and then they made nooses out of these
wires like phone wires and stuff and you
know kind of put them around everybody's
necks and then all of the the 10 members
of the family that you know hanged in
the Banyan Tree formation they stood on
they had five stools in a circle and so
two would stand on each stool
um now what happened with the older lady
that they found like the 80 year old
woman that they found in the other room
uh lolit actually did strangle her
because they said he said in the thing
and apparently this was planned and she
went along with it was that she was too
old and too heavy to kind of like
manipulate into that situation so they
said well you're gonna have to do it
laying down and she apparently I don't
think she fought or anything like that
so she actually was strangled in the
other room
and so he kind of set everybody up first
and then him and his wife like got on
one of the stools and you know kind of
did their own did each other's thing
okay hold on I must have been in the
restroom or I missed it right what what
was the rationale of why we all had to
die at this point I haven't got to that
yet I haven't got to that okay okay all
right because yeah because I was like
wait hold on they're doing this already
yeah what's the reason okay we'll get to
it yeah and Ben says uh the Banyan tree
is a symbol of immortality and Hinduism
yeah that's I kind of feel like that's
why but that's what they wanted it to
look like they wanted to be more
immortality yeah yeah that's what I mean
so that's why that's why what you were
saying earlier about like the the pipes
like being like to let the gases out I
don't think they actually thought they
were going to die okay I mean it doesn't
seem like they thought they were going
to I think they thought that they were
going to
transcend or something or that Daddy was
going to save them or something they
were going to link up with a hellbot
comment yeah it was kind of like that I
really don't think that they thought
they were actually going to hang
themselves right like it they they
thought they were doing this particular
ritual and if they did it the right way
then they would either like achieve
salvation or achieve immortality or
whatever okay
so yeah so I so I don't know if that
body thing like works out so Tina she
was like the only one that didn't have
her hands tied behind her back because
she was the one that had to like finish
everything off so she got up on the
stool put the Noose around her own neck
and I guess like at a pre-ordained
signal they all kicked their stools over
and uh you know just hung there from the
electrical wires and uh basically it's
just kind of like because in the notes
this is why I think that they didn't
think they were they were actually gonna
die
um lalit wrote in his diary
that his dead father had said the Earth
will shake and the sky will open up but
don't worry chant the Mantra louder I
will come to save you and the others
and then later on when he's talking
about the instructions for the ritual
um the note said everyone will tie their
hands themselves but when the ritual is
over everyone will help each other untie
their hands okay so they didn't think
they were gonna die yeah they thought
that they were you know the same guy
who's
who's uh scrying all this from across
the [ __ ] great beyond
he killed himself too he believed it huh
yeah they all did
they all did
um so basically after they read
all of those uh Diaries
the cops were like oh well that we know
exactly what happened now because it did
kind of like line up with every with all
of the evidence wild [ __ ] and uh they
actually rolled it unintended mass
suicide
yeah they thought they were going to
come back because they thought that they
said India's got a bunch of different
religions and a bunch of different
religious [ __ ] traditions and
even the Indians didn't know what the
[ __ ] this was it took a while to figure
it out okay this isn't normal for them
all right but I can see how
maybe they thought
they could survive that
yeah okay it's just I mean they really
did seem to believe that I mean they
come from they come from a tradition
that has religions that
say a bunch of different things there's
a lot of conflict and depend on whatever
[ __ ] little cult you're in and this
is just this particular cult thought
they could do that they're talking about
basically Heaven's Gate this is
basically Heaven's Gate yeah that's the
vibe that I got yeah it's very much like
that but like I said they really didn't
seem to believe it yeah yeah Ben said
the Buddha achieved Enlightenment by
sitting under a banyan tree yeah that's
right yeah I said didn't the father die
from some illness yeah I think it was
just like a respiratory illness he just
died of like regular like natural causes
you know what I mean
and then like after that like I said
they couldn't handle it and it seemed
like they all kind of went crazy now as
I mentioned earlier uh bovnesh the 50
year old guy uh it seemed like he tried
to free himself in the last minute
because like I said they found his hand
like up here uh one of his hands was
free and they found his hand like up
here like he had loosened his hand it
was like maybe changed his mind at the
last minute
um and his feet were actually touching
the ground they did actually show the
photos like they did show their feet you
know because they had
this is [ __ ] up but they said we hated
having to do this but they said we had a
number all the corpses it was 10 of them
and it's like they just wrote like Drew
numbers like on a piece of paper and
like put them down by everybody's feet
so yeah so that was like [ __ ] up but
yeah they said that the dad did um
did like look like he had tried to get
free but the other ones it didn't really
seem like that it really seemed like
everybody was on board with it maybe the
dude just like changes my the last thing
like oh [ __ ] this isn't like it you know
it doesn't feel good or I don't feel
good about this and he seemed like but
it was too late you know what I mean
well he's choking out right so you're
trying to trying to stay you're not
thinking
and the [ __ ] up thing too is that even
though nobody looked like they struggled
but
um I I will note that the teenagers
because they were some of them were 15.
they did like tie their feet together
like really tightly and they tied their
hand like more tightly than any of the
others so maybe they thought that like
they would try to like get out of it
more than the other ones would
so so they did say that yeah and like I
said like every single person that went
into that because they talked to like a
bunch of people that like the cops and
like the the friend of theirs that like
found them and stuff and they were just
like that was like the [ __ ] that was
the worst thing they'd ever [ __ ] seen
can you imagine that they haven't even
lived yet can you imagine like walking
into and seeing 10 people just like hey
that'd be so [ __ ] creepy oh my God
here's the thing
a rational person
reach reaching the Age of Reason
you see this kind of [ __ ] you see the
tragedy in it and you're like why the
[ __ ] have why what does it mean you know
and you're like wow that's some [ __ ]
up [ __ ]
but don't do that
don't read into it too much
these people were misguided you know
yeah and this is a rare instance
yeah I mean [ __ ] like this hardly ever
happens yes to be honest I mean that's
the reason we're talking about it
because it's crazy it's uh
they're misguided they may not have been
the smartest people in the world too you
know and uh this is something that they
decided to do because they believed in
some [ __ ] wacko [ __ ] I've seen
paranormal stuff I wouldn't do this
[ __ ] no like I said I I can't really
imagine that you thought that you could
tell me that would make some [ __ ] like
that so this kind of goes along I put
this in the category of [ __ ] cult
mass suicide kind of like Heaven's Gate
yeah like who actually legitimately did
believe that they were going on the hail
Bob Comet and yeah the spaceship Lincoln
they were linking up with a Mothership
yeah so they could Escape [ __ ] being
pedophiles
the weird thing about this though is it
kind of seemed like a little bit it kind
of seemed like a little bit the same uh
situation as the family in the atom
house but the interesting thing about
like in the atom house it seemed like
their dad died and then they completely
like cut themselves off yeah that
doesn't seem to have been the case with
this family nobody like everybody knew
these people they ran a store like
everybody in the neighborhood knew them
they said they were awesome like they
like I said they baby stopped people's
kids like they had just had like a big
party that everybody came to like a
wedding or engagement or whatever and
they're like they were acting totally
totally normal and it was so it wasn't a
case where they'd like isolated
themselves and then went into like a
feedback loop of like crazy beliefs
what's happening is that they're happy
okay and they're in good spirits because
they think they have special information
coming to them throughout the grave yeah
so that they're they they have an
advantage over other people so they're
happy but this is a false belief yeah
this guy who's channeling this
information is either a lunatic or or
evil probably more of a lunatic if you
ask me probably mentally ill I'm kind of
getting more of the idea I don't really
know like I said you know
um nobody that knew him seemed to think
that he was like malevolent in any way
I'd say lunatic so I think that he was
just like misguided I think maybe he
probably really did believe that his dad
like his was talking to him
you don't even know the patriarch would
say he thought that but I think he
thought that because he's crazy well
yeah I didn't say that I'm just saying
lunatic but I'm just saying that not
malevolent in the sense that oh I know
this is [ __ ] but it's just like he
got off on like manipulating his family
members
now Ron Hubbard on a [ __ ] he did
yeah he thought he was the source
yeah it was like that yeah it was like
that yeah but um yeah so they
legitimately like they really seem to
believe that they weren't gonna die that
they were gonna get saved or something
like if they did the ritual right which
is yeah it's really sad if that's true
um now I really like that the
documentary because I was worried about
the dog okay yeah
you know how I do well I mean the people
were already the dog's innocent the dogs
that the Netflix documentary they
actually had the guy on there that had
rescued the dog and he talked about the
dog
um you know in a way that I would talk
about the dog he's like he's like this
baby he's like he didn't you know he he
couldn't do anything he was just like
trapped up there like watching these
people like dying and he's like freaking
out so he did actually like rescue the
dog uh the dog's name was Tommy like I
said Tommy Tommy yeah
um yeah now the sad thing about it
though because I was like please tell me
somebody saved that little baby but they
did they rescued the dog they put him in
a shelter for a little while they said
now he was kind of messed up at first
like they he was he wouldn't eat or
drink or anything I'm like well
obviously because he saw some [ __ ] up
[ __ ] because dogs like they [ __ ] have
emotions too
um they said he got back to normal like
after a while like he was just you know
eating drinking playing doing stuff like
that but
um only like a couple weeks later he
died of heart failure the dog did weird
and he was only six oh weird and I was
like oh is is that sad yeah because I
was like I'm just I'm just really really
glad that like the Netflix Doctor I'm
glad that they had a guy on there that
was like the animal lover that was just
like the poor dog and I was like right
thank you you know what I mean because I
was like please tell me somebody did
something about that poor little puppy
but so I like that they had somebody on
there that that talked about that that
saved the dog but unfortunately the dog
died anyway even though they thought
that he was getting back to normal and I
was like oh God damn it that makes the
story even sadder holy [ __ ] now what
ended up happening after this like
probably not surprisingly was that the
house where this happened because it's
not even a thing where like the Adam
house you know in Bangladesh that's kind
of become like a notorious location just
because that family lived there even
though they didn't die in the house like
I said they jumped in front of a train
but in this house in this case those
people did die in that house 11 people
hang to themselves in this [ __ ] house
so obviously they're like now in this
area like a Ferrari they said this is
like the [ __ ] Amityville house up in
here like everybody thinks it's like
haunted as [ __ ] which it probably is to
be honest with you
um so yeah they're saying like yeah
there's like all 11 family members are
still like haunting it now there
actually was like an older brother who
didn't live there his name was Dinesh
and um he doesn't think that the family
actually died from this occult ritual
gone wrong I don't know if he thought
they were murdered because some people
still do think they were murdered and
that it was a cover-up
um he actually I guess he like inherited
the house after this uh tragedy and he's
been trying to sell it for a couple
years but obviously Lee nobody really
wants to buy it because Jesus Christ
um Jesus Christ you know what I mean
yeah it's like who the [ __ ] would want
to live I would even think twice about
that and I'm not real like you know
sensitive to that kind of thing and a
lot of dead people in that house yeah it
would be a little weird but the thing
about it is that you know any house you
buy that's old it's like you know who
knows how many dead people there could
have been of that house like especially
if you get an old house it's like I'm
sure at least one or two people died in
there and the thing about it is like
even the land under your house like
people have died on that [ __ ] too so
especially if you're in Europe yeah Rome
yeah it's like people have died on every
[ __ ] square inch it's like so I
wouldn't worry too much about it
um you know what I mean but I mean at a
location like this where something like
that happened that like I said I kind of
feel like you would just be imagining it
because I can't imagine like how creepy
can you imagine like you know walking up
the stairs and just seeing like 10
people just hanging it was probably like
really quiet and they were all just like
hanging there dead that's like you know
what I mean that's got to be like
[ __ ] horrible I can't imagine like
coming across something like that so uh
so yeah so the guy's been trying to sell
the house obviously not really getting
any takers
now for a little while
um two guys who had worked for lalit at
the plywood shop
um they actually were kind of like
renting the place out like as a favor
like while he was trying to sell it and
they basically said yeah this house is
creepy as [ __ ]
um and they actually wouldn't even go
into that room like where that happened
like for a long time like for the first
few months they lived there uh they
actually slept like out on the [ __ ]
terrorists like out of the patio because
they wouldn't go like into that room
um and then but then they got used to it
after a while and they said it was okay
um and then like later on I think they
rented it to like some like doctor that
runs like a Pathology lab or something
like that
um and he hasn't really I don't think
he's reported any Paranormal Activity
but like I said that the house does have
like a reputation so like I said if you
have Netflix
um there's a documentary on there and
it's called House of Secrets the burari
deaths and I only saw like the first two
episodes but it seemed like really
really interesting so if you want to
know I'm sure they kind of went more
into uh more details than what I came up
with but because I didn't get a chance
to watch it all but I did fill in stuff
from like the first couple episodes but
it seemed like really really good and
like really interesting and that's
really seems like the main source of
info about this because you know there's
more info about it than there was about
the atom house but there's still not a
lot and a lot of it is not in English so
but uh I'm glad somebody recommended
that this because that's like a [ __ ]
creepiest yeah it's an interesting story
Jeffy Hart said oh the poor puppy I know
yeah yeah and Rebecca said poor dog the
stress and recall yeah and I'm imagining
it's probably
because dogs man dogs are smarter than
you think they are yeah well animals in
general are Smarter Than People dog knew
that all those people died yeah well I'm
not really sure I think they'd been
hanging there for because I think they
hanged themselves like overnight and
then they weren't found until like the
next morning yeah so the dog was tied
there and was like you know and so it
was up there for like several hours yeah
and I can't imagine like that poor dog
like what that poor dog went through
like not really know what was it I'd
like to do an investigation or an
autopsy find out why that dog really
died
I don't I don't believe it was heart
failure
an animal can Will themselves to die
yeah maybe he was just like yeah yeah I
don't need this [ __ ] too much stress the
family was gone and there's like well
here
dog couldn't compute what had happened
well yeah because the dog doesn't really
understand and like and then suddenly
the whole family is gone because they're
their relatives said he was like the
12th member of the family like you know
what I mean like the dog was right so
all 11 people being gone now and he
doesn't understand why I think the dog
shut himself down he might have yeah
which is sad that's really sad like I
said that just made it like
exponentially sadder like it was sad
enough to start with but then like the
poor the poor dog that like [ __ ]
happened with that yeah oh my God worked
with animals for a living you know
horses and stuff and [ __ ] dogs into
the air they're smarter than you think
they are yeah they're within their own
little confines of whether or not
they're an opportunist type animal or a
or a herd animal uh but a dog is a dog
is a social pack animal
and uh they have a good understanding of
family
and uh
relationships and that dog saw the dog
knew something was wrong yeah that's his
entire pack and it's gone yeah the dog
knew that they that dog knew that his
pack killed itself
and uh everything is new its family is
gone because that's their family the
pack is the family yeah so the family
killed herself dog now I think the dog
willed itself to die maybe yeah that's
just like we're very loyal because
somebody would have adopted him yeah you
know what I mean wouldn't have been the
same for the demo but that's what
happened to that dog I think I don't
believe heart failure now
broken heart well that's probably what
they came up with because they're broken
think of anything else
which yeah it can happen yeah Rebecca
said I'll look it up on Netflix it
sounds like a horror movie yeah I mean
I'm not sure about Australia Netflix but
it's on it's on Indian Netflix and it's
on American Netflix so I imagine it's on
other ones and others and if you have
like a VPN you can watch stuff from
other countries you know what I mean so
if you want some tacos
uh sure I'll make us some tacos really
you don't want to talk about food on the
on the show anymore no I'm getting too
hungry
I got I got Carnitas down there I got
the end of the carnita oh that's right
yeah yeah I got Cardinals he made me
some crab salad today I have uh yeah I
have [ __ ] queso uh queso um fryer
fryer which is kind of like queso Bronco
queso fresco oh that nice cheese or
whatever yeah it's Spanish cheese
but you know it's so much cheaper you
can get
owaka is expensive here from our Mexican
listeners
our local uh Mexican market here has a
lock of cheese on it which is kind of
like string cheese that's what an
American would call it
it was six dollars just for a little
tiny amount of it
for six bucks I could get a big old
thing of [ __ ] queso fresco which is
not quite the same but
well what was the cheese that you put on
the burrito the other day
that was uh that was the new one freyr
that was good that was good it's good
yeah it doesn't melt quite the same but
it's good no that was okay well I kind
of liked it because it was a little bit
toothy yeah yeah chewy yeah a little bit
chewy kind of almost like a mozzarella
yeah but like a little bit a little bit
between a mozzarella and a [ __ ] um in
an Indian uh cottage cheese which would
be kind of like uh like paneer like
paneer but melty you can't melt paneer
no yeah I love paneer though yeah paneer
is good vineyard's good [ __ ] just fried
fried inside of [ __ ] SOG or something
I used to like that Indian restaurant we
went to Fifth Element yeah they they
made a really good
um like it was like tikka masala but it
was had paneer in it instead of chicken
I bet you they're up and running again
we need to go back you want to go back
yeah well they were up and running a
while back but this I didn't they didn't
have to they didn't have the Buffet open
they were just like they just had like
the regular restaurants we need to get
back to full [ __ ] Force man
and memories of India
been a while since we've been to that
yeah I love memories yeah their their
lamb korma is this [ __ ] so everything
they have is good everything they have
is good but like their lamb korma is my
favorite well and I usually get that
when we go there because we don't
usually buy lamb at home and we don't
usually make it yeah Conn's talking
about a Waka yeah man [ __ ] a Waka is
good can't tell me about a walk they
sell it here at the Mexican market but
it's six dollars for just a small amount
of it
and um it's good it's not that different
it's what's she doing what the [ __ ]
can you see her it's like string cheese
but it's not that different from like a
good mozzarella or
but yeah I had it it's good
it's good it's just I laughed because I
saw her little feet behind there going
like she was over I got all kinds of
good [ __ ] at the at the market man the
Mexican market I'm gonna go back there
and I'm gonna hit that that's not far
from here though it's only a couple of
Miles like down the road yeah somebody
asked for like for the uh hold on a
second hold on a second
somebody asked for the worse
so I had to do I'm looking at this [ __ ]
like it's something's gonna happen
nothing's gonna happen with it I think
maybe she's afraid it's gonna fall on
her she's gonna fall now she wants to
fight because well that's the thing like
that that fan it's kind of like when it
only has one speed like it's
you know ostensibly it's supposed to
have three speeds I think because most
fans do oh my goodness
but for whatever reason you can pull on
the thing and it's just it's like either
fast or off
but it's like
it came with the house you know and it
just and it kind of like rattles like
that like it's so whenever you turn it
on like I think Pookie is always like
looking at like oh [ __ ] that's gonna
fall off okay you know what I mean
yeah where's the man said I could I
still didn't make one I still made one
yeah I wrote it down but I forgot I
forgot about it I got busy today
all right so uh I guess we're gonna wrap
it up right yeah
Tom's talking about making some tacos so
we're gonna go make some tacos yeah and
no no [ __ ] con if this is this isn't
a maseka tacos the tortillas are already
pre-made but I do make my own tortillas
all right for you all questioning people
out there
Honky Kong can make his own tortillas
see it's like a concert that makes me a
honorary Mexican you should start a
company called honky tortillas I'ma
Gotta Have I gotta get a Honky Kong
shirt going yeah okay I gotta get a
honky sure going yeah
I told Pookie last night because pookie
I was uh watching we were watching a
movie last night and Pookie came up and
started making biscuits like on my lap
and I told her that um that I was gonna
make her like a little apron that said
Pookie's Biscuit Company on it because
she's always like I'm naked she's always
making biscuits like on my chest when I
was laying in bed
um yeah you need to I make my own
tortilla shirt yeah it's like we got so
many shirts I come down here to Mexico
to come see you bro I'm gonna have a
[ __ ] tortilla shirt on they're gonna
be like I'm [ __ ] crazy like what
honky tongues tortillas honky Kong's
white ass tortillas
[ __ ] it that's what we need to do what
we need to do is we need to open up a
restaurant together man [ __ ] I'll get
some yeah you guys should I get some of
this Gringo money and I'll take that
[ __ ] down there to [ __ ] Mexico or
something or we'll bring it we'll build
it up here in Florida
I don't know it'll probably be cheaper
to do it down there
I make a [ __ ] uh uh uh
an American restaurant you do a food
truck yeah or a food truck that'd
probably be good because you'd get it on
the ground floor because they're not I
mean they're not that expensive make
some American food so just it's
breakfast 20 American breakfast 24 7
breakfast sandwiches see that [ __ ]
English muffins and [ __ ] yeah I wish
there were more places like that like I
know there's Waffle House and Denny's
and stuff like that but I do kind of
feel like even like really good yeah
um like breakfast brunch places like
first watch or um whatever that other
one is that's like a chain those are
usually just like open in the morning
they're open like in the morning like
till two o'clock in the afternoon
breakfast any day and I was like well
what about all us drunk [ __ ]
who who want some breakfast at three
o'clock in the morning yeah what about
what about uh what about our names
I take a pancake and you put eggs and
bacon and cheese and you roll it up like
a burrito even put [ __ ] maple syrup
in it and eat it like that and give that
to the Mexicans they would [ __ ] love
that [ __ ] I would love that [ __ ] I would
love that [ __ ] everybody in the world
would love that [ __ ] breakfast burrito I
can't imagine anybody in the world not
loving that I'm a damn pancake yummy
[ __ ] dripping out the bottom while
you're eating it [ __ ] Mexico
understands that kind of I thought the
white Mexican Grill
[Laughter]
homemade tequila yeah that's your
calling Tom yeah we have Jenny come down
visit [ __ ] in a low-cut outfit I'm
not working in the brothel though I know
I know what you're getting to right you
don't want me to work it you don't want
me to work in the brothel remember that
Mexican dudes getting them to come in
the [ __ ] front of the store get it
come in here have a pancake
pass some eggs
oh my God all right man let's shut it
down James all right we're gonna go make
some tacos uh and hopefully you have a
good day tomorrow we're taking tomorrow
off like we usually do on Thursday but
we will be back on Friday doing our side
track show having drinking a chat about
whatever like we usually do
um but you know so hopefully we see you
guys then hopefully you guys enjoy the
show this evening thank you for hanging
out with us and we will see you again on
Friday good night